It was courtside,
sitting next to him.
I can't remember what game it was, but,
but my experience is kind of the opposite.
He's so locked in. He doesn't break.
So, like, saying what's
up to him in warm-up lines,
all that good stuff was cool.
But then when the game was
on, sitting, like,
two seats away from
him, you know what I mean?
It's just kinda like how focused
he is on what he's in the
middle of and what he's doing.
Even when you try to get,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, you know, “Hey, I’m still sitting here.
Same guy
you said what's up to.
Like, we know each other.
We actually worked together.”
- Like, talk to me.
- Nothing? OK, cool.
It's like you respect the workplace,
you know what I'm saying?
And the drive of like of what
mission he's out on right now.
So that was just like, you know,
the opposite of how—
not the opposite, but just,
he just was so locked in.
It was, it was, you know,
always impressive.